[Music]
so we're doing a cup test with you yeah
this lightweight is gonna punch you in
the cup is that all right i told aaron
it was a
lightweight didn't tell him it was a
heavy weight
that's not a flight wait what are you
talking about
you lied to me i meant heavyweight but
lightweight came out
i'm a ufc fan so i heard francis and
gone i was going to be there and i was
like i want to do it please please and
then later i found out in fact i didn't
want to do it
i just googled the hardest punch ever
recorded his punch is the equivalent of
being hit by a ford escort at top speed
why you don't need to read that now
[Laughter]
you waited until the fourth theatrical
release to become a real star
the world waited for what felt like
forever
then
[Applause]
we waited longer
but this february
we promise it's gonna be the gnarliest
[__] ever
the wait is over
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough
if they trust us to go to the bathroom
they're less intelligent than i thought
i've been in the drawer but i know
enough
to know
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough you're still blowing people up as
if life's not hard enough this guy's one
badass dude
oh man i'm on jackass is it texas rat
snake venomous
francis hits harder than any heavyweight
in mma i told aaron it was a lightweight
[Music]
what's the worst that could happen
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything
i just need you to like sit with my
grandpa just make sure he doesn't smoke
a bunch of nasty scientists right now
can i get a cold breed
will you make him an actual coffee
stephanie here i made another one
it's gotta be over dude i think we're
all the way finished with fruit
stick or fork in it
[Music]
bye